elon musk is the billionaire ceo of
spacex and tesla and was ranked by
forbes as number 21
on their list of the world's most
powerful people he went from being
raised by his abusive father in the
suburbs of south africa
to now being the 20th richest person in
the world with a net worth of 41.1
billion dollars
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
nation top
high 10 my top 10.99
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
that you know
but you also know that you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best elon musk and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one accept
failures when trying different things
you've got to
have some acceptance of failure as
you're alluding to earlier
failure must be an option if failure is
not an option it's going to result in
extremely conservative choices
and you may not may get something even
worse than
lack of innovation things may go
backwards
so if what you really want
is
[Applause]
risk risk to you you want reward and
punishment
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if uh if what you're seeking is
innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and only
there's there should be minor
consequences for lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
should there should be minor um
significant rewards for trying and
succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding
and big and major negative consequences
for not
trying rule number two overcome doubt
or maybe i just blank out the word doubt
um
[Laughter]
so no i mean i tritoli frank i doubted
us too
so i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right
you know um i mean there were times
that i was told like uh because i was
taking the
money i earned from from paypal and
enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all
it wasn't the intention but um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um and uh so but a lot of times i was
you know i people would tell me this
joke like how do you make a small
fortune in
the rocket industry you start with a
large one is the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so anyway um and it was it almost came
true
um you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch and then
uh and that wasn't even enough to save
the company we also then had to win the
national cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later
or towards the end of 2008 those are the
two
key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know not made it so
um so hey i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately
uh vader smiled upon us and brought us
to this day
rule number three limit mistakes as you
look back on your career in the space
industry
what has been the most surprising or
unexpected challenge that you faced
and along those lines if you were to go
back in time and talk to your 20 year
old self
would you do anything differently
go back in time to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd if i could i think it
would make a lot
far fewer mistakes obviously if i could
go like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
yeah wouldn't we be a very long list i'm
like
here let me write it down or something
you know
um i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i have a lot count
honestly um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i'd like that like that's
simple sort of mantra management by
rhyming
i mean it worked for homer okay um
the management by rhyming is
the thing i was saying like if but if
the schedule's long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
with the acid test being how long will
it take to
for this to fly and if it's gonna take a
long time
don't do it do something else rule
number four push for radical
breakthroughs
i think we we need to push for radical
breakthroughs
um and if you don't push radical
breakthroughs
you're not going to get radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks um
and and yeah common sense that
the if you take a big risk in order to
have a big reward there must be a big
risk
it's most the time you cannot find
a big reward for small risk that's those
are rare
so you're gonna have some
proportionality the risk can reward
also if you want to have more confidence
and learn from billionaires check out my
254 series they're free
the links are joined in the description
below there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear starting
companies like staring into your bus and
eating glass when you want to do
something new you have to
you have to apply the physics approach
rule number five
optimize really just
simplify your product as much as
possible
um
you know and then like if i think of
some of the ways which how does a smart
engineer make dumb mistakes
including you know
is optimize something that shouldn't
exist
don't optimize something that shouldn't
exist um but people are trained to do
this in college
you can't say no to the professor you
know the professor's going to give you
the exam and you've got to answer all
the questions
or they'll get angry
so and give you a bad grade so then you
you always optimize the you always
answer the question
a lot of times you should say this is
the wrong question
right in fact the question is definitely
wrong to some degree just how wrong
[Music]
um and i think just generally taking the
approach that
your design is some degree wrong
probably a lot more than you think
your goal is to make it less wrong over
time rule number six
always look for improvement one of the
fun things for me is watching the
the the cargo go into the crew vessel
you know all of a sudden we had
dragon one now we have crew dragon and
it's substantially different but
familiar so tell us like what's been
some of the hardest parts to transition
from cargo
into crew because the crew is a little
more important than
than cargo yes i mean cargo can be
replaced
crew cannot um and so the the level of
scrutiny
the level of attention is
i mean i don't know order of magnitude
greater it was it was already high for
cargo i mean
and and uh but it's it's just a whole
nother level for
for a crew um so you know after and
after i told the spacex team that you
know the
uh this mission reliability is not
really the top priority it is the only
priority right now
um so we're just doing continuous uh
engineering reviews
uh from now non-stop 24 hours a day
until launch
just gone over everything again and
again and again and i was out at the pad
just recently just walking down the
rocket
um we've got a team that's just crawling
over the rocket in the horizontal
then we're going to rotate it vertical
then we're going to crawl all over in
the vertical
and we're just looking for
any any possible action that can improve
the probability of success no matter how
small
whether that comes from an intern or me
or anyone it doesn't matter rule number
seven
innovate what sort of things do you look
for in people
or in processes that make the workforce
better
sure well i think the massive
thing that can be done is to make sure
your incentive structure is such that
uh innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished
there's got to be a characteristic so
if somebody is innovating
and during making great good progress
then they should be promoted sooner um
and if somebody is
completely failing to innovate um not
every role requires innovation
but uh if they're in a role where
innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited and let
me tell you you'll get promote you could
you'll you'll get innovation real fast
rule number eight
use management by rhyming so now your
actual total mass of a steel
uh a reusable steel spacecraft is less
than that of the most advanced carbon
fiber
vehicle you could possibly imagine yeah
wow but this
happened by accident by the way this may
sound like some great insight but
it actually happened because we were
moving too slowly on composite
and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt so
just get do this with steel so yeah i
mean the design has to be
focused on problem solving otherwise
you're going to spend too much time
trying to figure you don't start with a
yeah
yeah i'm like sort of taken to
management management by rhyming
if the schedule is your schedule is long
your design is wrong
right this is a very true
good point yes rule number nine be a
problem solver
zip2 started off um as basically
uh like i said we're trying to figure
out how to how to make enough money to
exist as a company and the
so since there wasn't really any
advertising money being made
we thought we could um help existing
companies
get online bring their stuff online so
we developed software that
helped bring um local newspapers and
media companies online because they
alone just didn't
they also didn't know what the internet
was or the customers didn't yeah
um and even the ones that were aware of
the internet didn't have a software team
so they
could they weren't very good at
developing functionality
um and so we had as investors and
customers
the new york times company night reader
host and
and so we were able to get them to pay
us to develop software for them to bring
them online so online publishing stuff
we did maps and directions and yellow
pages and
white pages and various other things and
rule number 10 the last one before very
special bonus clip
is plan perfect dates i met a woman
i did briefly in college who now works
at scientific american as a writer
and uh and and she she related the
anecdote that uh
we were on a date i was all i was
talking about was electric cars
um that was not a big a winning
conversation
so it was a bit of a monologue was it
yeah she said she she said the first
question i asked her was do you ever
think about electric cars
she never does so so you'll learn from
that that wasn't the best yeah i don't
like it
it wasn't great but it has
recently it's been more effective
now i've got a special bonus skip from
elon on how to work towards your goals
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that question of the day i
want to know
what is the internal doubt that you have
that you need to
overcome let me know put it down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far in a video you're still here
watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below
i want to celebrate you we don't just
watch videos here
we do something about it so give me that
belief in the comments below
too i mean i'm really quite overcome uh
with emotion on this day it's kind of
hard to talk frankly
um it's been 18 years working towards
this goal
so it's hard to believe that it's
happened
when we haven't quite yet doctored the
space station and of course we need to
bring them back safely and we need to
repeat these missions
and have this be a regular occurrence
so it's a lot of work to do but
it's uh it's just incredible
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out continue to believe
and i'll see you there